der möglicherweise ein Tag der
Entscheidung in der Ukraine laute
Russland bereitet sich die Ukraine auf
die Rückeroberung also auf die Befreiung
der großstadtration vor und nicht nur
das putin will heute eine
Dringlichkeitssitzung seines
Sicherheitsrates abhalten und auch ein
weiteres wichtiges sicherheitsgremium
soll sich heute um 17 Uhr Moskauer Zeit
dazu treffen wir schauen uns mal an was
dazu bisher veröffentlicht wurde nämlich
diese Aufnahmen hier das der Marionette
von Moskau incherson die nämlich gestern
Abend erklärt hat ja wir haben
Informationen dass die Ukraine ein
Großangriff Staaten auf herson und die
Nazis und der beste arbeiten hier
zusammen um eben die Stadt anzugreifen
und deshalb fordern wir Sie auf zu
evakuieren das heißt russland fordert
tatsächlich ungefähr 100.000 Menschen
auf zu evakuieren aus herson und diese
Aufnahmen sind ganz frisch von heute
morgen hier sieht man angeblich wie die
Evakuierung vonstatten geht das ganze
man muss es betonen angeblich denn es
ist noch nicht überhaupt nicht klar dass
so eine offensive tatsächlich vonstatten
geht von Seiten der Ukraine hier gibt es
keine offiziellen Informationen vom
Morgen und auch keine visuelle
Bestätigung also wir haben keine Bilder
von einer Offensive oder Beschuss aber
die Russen scheinen das zu erklären
warum es nicht ganz klar und wir schauen
uns das ganze mal auf der Karte an hier
der Süden des Landes eben die Region
Karlsson und wir sehen die die Lage hier
ich habe schon einmal südlich des großen
Flusses nördlich der Krim aber eben
dieser kleine Teil dieser rote Teil
nördlich destinierte und dort gibt es
angeblich eine ukrainische Großoffensive
so die Russen sie sagen dass dieses wir
sehen dieses blaugebiet hier was in
Person schon befreit wurde von den
Ukrainern das jetzt eben der Angriff von
hier und von hier auf reson-stadt
stattfindet und die Ukrainer das
komplett befreien wollen es ist aber
auch möglich dass es sich hier um
Propaganda handelt denn die Russen
wollen zum einen rechtfertigen dass sie
die ukrainische Infrastruktur die
weiteren Kraftwerke angreifen jeden Tag
und zum anderen wissen wir auch seit
Tagen dass die Russen die Ukraine diese
hier ja gefangen genommen haben die sie
eben auch annektiert haben dass sie die
eben unbedingt in eigenes Gebiet erholen
wollen damit die eben nicht wieder und
unter ukrainische Herrschaft kommen
insofern könnte das auch eine
propagandalist sein
wir müssen abwarten was der Tag dort
bringt weitere Probleme für die Russen
sind aber
dass die ukrainische Luftabwehr bei
ihren verheerenden Angriffen auf
Kraftwerke und Züge und heute morgen
auch ein Krankenhaus weiterhin aktiv ist
wir haben hier ein Video von vorgestern
was hier ein russischen Marschflugkörper
vom Typ ch-101 zeigt und wir sehen jetzt
gleich wie dieser Marschflugkörper von
der Ukraine abgeschossen wird da sehen
wir eine mächtige Explosion in der Luft
dieser erwartungskörper hat also nicht
sein Ziel erreicht die Russen reagieren
darauf nämlich um die Ukraine weiterhin
angreifen zu können nutzen Sie Ihre
Hightech-Waffen ihre sogenannten landset
Kamikaze drohen um ukrainische
Luftabwehr auszuschalten und wir sehen
hier ein Video aus saporisha von so
einer Drohne und ganz interessant ist
dass die Drohne tatsächlich bis kurz vor
dem Einschlag ihren eigenen Kurs hier
filmt und eben zeigt was sie trifft
nämlich hier ein ukrainisches
s300-system das sind Flugabwehrsystem
wir sehen hier oben diese kann man
gleich noch mal sehen die vier Öffnungen
wo die vier Raketen rausgeschossen
werden das also der russische Angriff
auf diese S300 hier sind wir die vier
Raketen und das Interessante ist dass
die Landwirt eben nicht alleine arbeitet
sondern auch wie die iranischen
kamikazedonen im Schwarm wir sehen also
hier von einer weiteren lenset
aufgezeichnet wie die erste hineingeht
auch immer für den Fall dass Sie in das
Ziel verfehlt deshalb ist die weitere
Drohne darüber guckt sich das Ganze an
und kann im Fall der Fälle im eingreifen
und selbst den Angriff ausüben das aus
saporisha wie gesagt ein weiteres Video
hat uns erreicht aus Mücke live ganz
ähnlich auch hier sehen wir eine
russische Lenze Drohne die jetzt auf ein
großes Anti Flugradar der Ukraine zu
fliegt wir sehen hier das Radar und auch
da sehen wir bis zum letzten Moment vor
dem Einschlag ich halte das mal ganz
kurz an bis zum letzten Moment vor dem
Einschlag also das Video und wir haben
sozusagen wenn man so will den Beweis
den die russische Armee liefert dass sie
eben wirklich diese dieses Radar
getroffen haben auch das wieder von oben
gefilmt wir sehen jetzt hier wie gleich
von der Seite ups da sehen wir es mal
relativ gut wie hier sich die russische
schon ernährt hier ist das Radar und
kurz danach haben wir eben den Einschlag
dort und wir sehen jetzt hier wie ist
das stört wurde das muss man dazu sagen
auch wenn die Russen mit ihren großen
Raketen und mit ihrem marschrotkörpern
und mit ihren iranischen Kamikaze drohen
eben die ukrainischen Städte angreifen
so versuchen sie trotzdem mit solchen
Angriffen eben im Süden des Landes vor
allem also zwischen den ukrainischen
Großstädten und dem russisch besetzten
Gebiet versuchen Sie weiter die
Luftabwehr so zu schwächen dass eben die
Angriffe auf Kraftwerke dort weitergehen
können und eben bis zum Winter so
scheint das der Plan der Russen zu sein
ein Großteil der ukrainischen
strominfrastruktur ist zerstört wird wir
wissen von Präsident lensky das allein
in den ersten acht Tagen dieser
russische Kampagne 30 Prozent der
ukrainischen Kraftwerke zerstört wurde
Russland scheint hier ganz sicher
stellen zu wollen dass es eben in den
nächsten Wochen ein Großteil der
ukrainischen Infrastruktur zerstört und
damit sowohl Strom als auch Wärme eben
den ukrainischen Menschen 35 Millionen
sind noch im Land nimmt
[Musik]